Valerie Bertelli and Eddie Van Halen had
an unbreakable bond that lasted until
his final moments on this
Earth Valerie was spotted for the first
time yesterday outside the home of her
and Eddie's 29-year-old son Wolf Gang
our source says he is taking the death
of his father particularly
hard Valerie revealed they were both by
Eddie's side when he passed away from
cancer at just 65 years old she posted
this beautiful family snapshot with the
caption quote I'm so grateful Wolfie and
I were able to hold you in your last
moments I will see you in our next life
my love Eddie was remarried to his
second wife Janie since 2009 she paid
tribute on social media saying quote my
heart and soul have been shattered into
a million pieces a source close to the
family tells ET Eddie's cancer battle
took a turn for the worst this past
weekend he was on life support in the
hospital for more than 24 hours before
before he died Wolfie says hi can you
go ET has seen firsthand Through The
Years just how devoted of a father Eddie
was Wolfie even went on tour with Van
Halen starting in 2007 at first I was
like no no no you're not going on tour
with your dad then he he talked to me he
said listen Mom this is a chance for me
to really get close to Dad it really did
end up being a good thing for him Betty
and Wolfie in the same band come that's
what you uh family is everything at the
end of the
day I spoke with kiss frontman Jean
Simmons who has known Eddie from the
start he saw an unsigned Van Halen
perform in 1977 and produced their first
demo I was just honored and lucky enough
to be there to witness the greatness
before it exploded on the
world do you have a favorite memory with
Eddie yeah kiss was in the studio Eddie
called and said that he wanted to come
down and hey let me play you uh this
thing we just did
[Music]
he goes yeah yeah it's called you know
jump Eddie was a Visionary go home dim
the lights crank up the volume put on
some van
Halo I spoke exclusively with another
Rockstar reeling at Eddie's loss his
former tour mate Azie
Osborne
standby What will the Legacy of Eddie
Van Halen B he was phenomenal to watch
the guy you know to see a m up play an
instrument like a joy to watch he had so
much more to give I just feel so bad for
his family today John ban joobi told CBS
This Morning Eddie was a huge
inspiration for his own
career every teenager of my era couldn't
look at an electric guitar and not wish
that they could play like Eddie Van
Halen Guitar World magazine ranked Eddie
the number one greatest guitarist of all
time but did you know he's The
Mastermind behind this iconic guitar
solo Eddie was uncredited and unpaid for
that beat it Cameo ET was on set of that
legendary video in
1983 back to Jean Simmons he told me
that at one point Eddie tried to quit
Van Halen and join kiss because he
wasn't getting along with one of his
bandmates thankfully Jean talked him out
of it you know Eddie really will be
[Music]
missed